Our approach extends
procedural modeling methods
to generate structurally
feasible masonry buildings.
Here, a procedural model
is generated from a set
of grammatical rules.
Using our method,
we can automatically
find rule parameters that make
the model structurally sound.
The user can declare free
parameters to be optimized.
In this example, we
optimized the height.
Here, we show a real-time
capture of our optimization
as it iteratively
finds parameters.
The ceiling is
automatically lowered,
so the thin columns can resist
outward forces from the arches.
Now, we fixed the height and
optimized the column width.
And now, we optimize height and
column width simultaneously.
A second usage scenario
is interactive editing
of parameters.
Here, the angle of
the flying buttresses
is optimized to make
the structure stable.
Next, the user
decides to increase
the span of the ceiling.
Our system then automatically
updates the buttress angle
to maintain stability.
A core motivation
for stable models
is for interaction in physically
simulated environments.
In this tower of stacked
blocks, the structure
is unstable and collapses.
This stable structure
was generated
from a 20-parameter
optimization that
adjusted the horizontal
position of each block.
After a few ground shakes,
the structure collapses.
In this stacking arrangement, a
20% factor of safety was used.
After small ground
shakes, the structure
settles back to a
stable position.
Larger perturbations caused
the tower to collapse.
Here, we visualize
a stable structure
collapsing after the user
removes blocks from the model.
In this simulation,
the ground shakes
and the structure collapses.
And finally, a projectile
is launched at an aqueduct.